[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Christian Otto
für den Sport mit viel Fußball guten
Abend und das sind die Nachrichten
Themen von heute
Beistand gegen Russland Deutschland will
in Litauen dauerhaft 4.000 Soldaten
stationieren
41 Cent mehr Mindestlohn Gewerkschaften
kritisieren das als viel zu wenig
angesichts der hohen Inflation
und hitzeplan für Deutschland die
Regierung will Alte Kranke und Kinder im
Sommer schützen
[Musik]
der Aufstand in Russland am Wochenende
hat gezeigt wie instabil die politische
Lage dort ist heute kommt ein deutliches
Signal von der Bundesregierung sie will
in den kommenden Jahren die militärische
Präsenz an der Ostflanke der NATO
verstärken
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius kündigte
überraschend an bis zu 4000
Bundeswehrsoldaten und Soldatinnen
dauerhaft nach Litauen zu verlegen das
Land sieht sich von Russland bedroht es
grenzt an die russische Exklave
kaliliengrat und das mit dem Kreml
Verbündete Belarus aus Litauen Andrea
Maurer
Litauen NATO Großübung unter dem
Eindruck des Machtkampfes in Russland
hier wo Belarus Russlands Verbündeter
und mögliche sexil des wagnerführers
brigoshi nur wenige Kilometer entfernt
ist macht der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister eine überraschende
Zusage deutschland ist bereit dauerhaft
ein robuste Brigade in Litauen zu
stationieren
voraussetzung dafür ist es ist
angesprochen worden dass die
entsprechende Infrastruktur vorhanden
ist litauensspräsident fordert seit
Monaten militärische Dauerpräsenz der
deutschen zeigt sich heute dankbar und
drängen zugleich
wir tun alles damit die Infrastruktur
bis 2026 steht aber ich wäre nicht
traurig wenn mein Verteidigungsminister
der hier auch vor mir sitzt ist schon
2025 schafft
bisher sind die Soldaten nur zeitweise
stationiert oder kommen zu Übungen ins
Land jetzt geht es um die dauerhafte
Stationierung von 4.000 deutschen
Soldaten mit ihren Familien die
Erwartungen waren klar dass es dauerhaft
mehr geben soll jetzt wird man sehen wie
sich das nach und nach ausgestaltet und
dann bin ich mir sicher dass beide
Seiten natürlich auch mit dem Stück weit
Wandel auch in den Gesellschaften auch
aufgrund der gesamten
sicherheitspolitischen Lage
zurechtkommen müssen lange hat Litauen
gedrängt lange war Deutschland
zurückhaltend auch mit dem Verweis auf
die fehlende Infrastruktur heute nun die
überraschende Wende die Entscheidung
bedeutet auch eine Art Kulturwandel für
die Bundeswehr denn im Gegensatz zu
Großbritannien in den USA und Frankreich
hat Deutschland keine Tradition Truppen
dauerhaft in einem anderen Land zu
stationieren es ist eine Entscheidung im
Zeichen der sogenannten zeitenwände
viele Fragen sind noch offen
der Anführer der russischen
hat sich erstmals nach dem putscht
wieder zu Wort gemeldet vor knapp zwei
Stunden wurde eine 11-minütige audiobo
Botschaft des 62-Jährigen veröffentlicht
wo er sich aufhält und ob er sich
tatsächlich wie vereinbart ins Exil nach
Belarus zurückgezogen hat blieb offen
knapp 48 Stunden war es still um ihn
nachdem ihr pregorian sich von seinen
Fans in Roßdorf am Don verabschiedete
hinterließ er viele Fragezeichen was er
mit seinem Söldner Aufstand eigentlich
erreichen wollte heute eine Erklärung
via audiobootschaft wir haben den Marsch
der Gerechtigkeit nicht gemacht um die
russische Regierung zu stürzen aber er
hat schwerwiegende Sicherheitsprobleme
im Land aufgezeigt ziel war es die
Auflösung der wagnergruppe zu verhindern
zum ersten Juli sollten die Söldner in
die russische Armee integriert werden im
politischen Moskau bemüht man sich
geschlossen aufzutreten nicht ganz so
ratlos auszusehen eine Sitzung der
russischen Regierung übertragen im
Staatsfernsehen
die Geschlossenheit der Gesellschaft
aufrecht zu erhalten wir müssen als ein
Team zusammenarbeiten indem wir uns
hinter den Präsidenten stellen
auch diese Aufnahmen wohl ganz bewusst
veröffentlicht sie sollen sehr gescheugo
in der Ukraine zeigen unklar waren die
Bilder entstanden sind doch die
Botschaft ist klar der
Verteidigungsminister ist noch im Amt
die wagnergruppe hatte am Wochenende
erklärt ihnen Stürzen zu wollen
aus dem Kreml kein Wort zu dem Söldner
Aufstand Putin selbst tritt nur in einer
Videobotschaft in Erscheinung anlässlich
eines industrieforums der Präsident sei
geschwächt sagen viele Experten
nach dem Marsch von pregorian könnte
versucht werden Putin zu überreden auf
eine Teilnahme an den Wahlen im Jahr
2024 zu verzichten seine Figur ist
verblasst und er ist kein Garant mehr
für die Sicherheit und für die
Entwicklung des Landes
in Moskau wurde dieser Montag für
arbeitsfrei erklärt das Leben geht seine
normalen Gang zumindest vorerst
die Außenminister der EU halten die Lage
in Russland für unberechenbar beim
Treffen in Luxemburg wurde davor gewarnt
den innenpolitischen Druck auf Präsident
Putin als gutes Zeichen zu bewerten der
EU-Außenbeauftragte Borell sagte die
Europäische Union beobachte wachsam die
Situation nach der Revolte berichtet
es ist eine entspannte Atmosphäre bei
den EU-Außenministern in gefährlichen
Zeiten russlands Präsident Putin ist
angeschlagen in dieser Einschätzung sind
sich alle einig es geht um einen
innenpolitischen Machtkampf in Russland
und wir müssen uns nicht ein es ist nach
wie vor unklar was dort geschieht eine
verwirrende Lage in Moskau das Putins
macht Risse bekommen hat macht vielen in
Europa Sorge man muss ja wissen dass wir
in einem Land von einem Land reden was
6000 Atom sprenkämpfer darum ist die
Situation habe ich sehr eine große
dichterisierung kann erfolgen ist sehr
gefährlich die Politik der EU zu diesem
Krieg ein Balance sagt Europa
konzentriert sich auf die militärischen
Unterstützung der Ukraine gerade jetzt
will die eu-kirche helfen bei der gegen
Offensive voranzukommen dem ukrainischen
Außenminister Kollege der zugeschaltet
war sicher die EU weitere 3,5 Milliarden
Euro Militärhilfe zu
Ereignisse am Wochenende haben gezeigt
wir müssen die Ukraine weiter
unterstützen denn dieser Krieg zermürbt
das russische Machtsystem
die Kämpfe an der Front sind intensiv
und Russlands macht Systemkrise sind die
Antwort der EU Geschlossenheit und noch
mehr Unterstützung für die Ukraine
Tag 488 des Krieges in der Ukraine wir
blicken noch mal auf das Geschehen an
der Front aus Kiew heißt es heute die
Gegenoffensive im Süden des Landes sei
erfolgreich die Truppen hätten dort
inzwischen 130 Quadratkilometern befreit
auch im Osten im donezka Gebiet soll die
ukrainische Armee ein weiteres Dorf
rewino Pool zurückerobert haben
überraschend an der Front der
ukrainische Präsident der Orden an
Soldaten verliebt
ins Inland der Sieg des afd-kandidaten
bei der Landratswahl in Südthüringen hat
Besorgnis ausgelöst der Präsident des
Zentralrats der Juden Schuster nennt das
Ergebnis einen Dammbruch die Gefahr sei
größer als manche ist wahrnehmen würden
meinte der Vorsitzende der türkischen
Gemeinde in Deutschland zur huhu bei den
Parteien in Berlin hat die
Ursachenforschung begonnen
die AFD in Feierlaune das erste
landratsmandat errungen sieht sich die
teils rechtsextremistische Partei näher
an ihrem Traum von einer
Regierungsbeteiligung in Berlin ist
heute die Rede von einem dambruch die
Kanzlerpartei auf Fehlersuche die Ampel
hat ihre Politik in letzter Zeit zu
wenig erklärt nicht gut organisiert zum
Beispiel beim heizungsgesetz wir müssen
jetzt durchstarten unsere Konzepte für
die Modernisierung des Landes eben auch
voranbringen die AFD im Höhenflug
Wahlsieg in Sonneberg und ein Rekord
werden nach dem anderen in den
bundesweiten Umfragen ein Denkzettel für
die ampelpolitik so zumindest erklärt
der CDU-Chef die Erfolge der AFD und
befindet sich damit in seltener
Einigkeit mit der Linken wenn Sie die
Bevölkerung verlieren auf dem Weg den
sie mit einer solchen Transformation
gehen wollen und genau das ist jetzt
eingetreten dann dürfen sie sich über
solche Wahlergebnisse nicht wundern das
jetzt zum Beispiel der Finanzminister
Linda und der Kanzler Scholz immer noch
in dieser Sackgasse aufs Gas drücken
wollen und weitere Milliarden kürzen
wird sich zusätzlich als Gift für die
Demokratie herausstellen die AFD in
Thüringen wird vom dortigen
Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft ebenso
ihr ko-vorsitzender Björn höcke
thüringenwelt kommendes Jahr eine neuen
Landtag dort für die AFD die Umfragen
sogar an die Grünen auf der Suche nach
Gegenstrategien ganz konkret glaube ich
dass wenn wir Investitionen sprechen wir
da die gleichwertigen Lebensverhältnisse
die Stärkung von Regionen nach dem Osten
ganz nach oben priorisieren sollten der
Tag nach der Landratswahl in Sonneberg
Jubel bei der AFD bei den anderen
Fragezeichen
strategiesuche und Streit um
Verantwortung
was ist ein angemessener Mindestlohn
darüber gibt es immer wieder
Diskussionen bei der Einführung 2015
waren es 8,50 € pro Stunde vergangenes
Jahr erhöhte die Ampelkoalition per
Gesetz auf 12 Euro jetzt soll der
Mindestlohn weiter steigen kommendes
Jahr auf
12,41 und dann noch mal 2025 auf 12 Euro
das empfiehlt die verantwortliche
Kommission allerdings nur unter Protest
der Beteiligten Gewerkschaften lass
bodensack
ob als Kellnerin oder als Friseurin fast
15 Prozent der Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland arbeiten zumindestlohn die
jetzt geplanten Erhöhungen dürften keine
großen Sprünge zulassen vielfach werden
sie nicht einmal die Inflation
ausgleichen es war wohl ein hartes
Ringen zum ersten Mal hat die
mindestlohnkommission gegen die
Gewerkschaften entschieden für eine
Anpassung lediglich im Centbereich
konnten wir auf keinen Fall die Hand
reichen das war mit uns nicht zu machen
mit diesem Beschluss erleiden die fast 6
Millionen Mindestlohn Beschäftigten
einen enormen reale und Verlust in den
beiden kommenden Jahren da sich
Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer in der
Kommission nicht einigen konnten hat die
Vorsitzende entschieden offenbar zu
Zufriedenheit der Arbeitgeber
wir sind über das hinausgegangen was wir
ursprünglich im Blick hatten und sind
damit sowohl unserer tarifpolitischen
unserer staatspolitischen aber auch
unserer wirtschaftspolitischen
Verantwortung gerecht geworden der
Arbeitsminister bedauert zwar dass die
Entscheidung nicht im Konsens gefallen
sei kündigt aber an die Empfehlung
umzusetzen ich kann verstehen dass ich
einige mehr gewünscht haben dass es
heute in der Bundespressekonferenz auch
sehr sehr deutlich geworden aber es
beißt die Maus keinen Faden ab das ganze
hat eine rechtliche Grundlage
Mindestlohngesetz die
mindestlohnkommission hat nach Gesetz
eine Gesamtabwägung vorzunehmen das hat
sie getan mindestens 13,50 € hatten die
Gewerkschaften gefordert davon ist die
jetzige Erhöhung ziemlich weit entfernt
schauen wir auf eine auffällige
Entwicklung immer mehr Kinder werden zu
ihrem Schutz von Jugendämtern in Obhut
genommen
vergangenes Jahr waren es
66.400 so das Statistische Bundesamt das
sind 40 Prozent mehr als 2021 Hauptgrund
für diesen Anstieg mehr unbegleitet
eingereiste Minderjährige aus dem
Ausland wie Afghanistan oder Syrien dazu
kommen überforderte Eltern oder
Anzeichen für Vernachlässigung
viele Autokäufer die in der
Vergangenheit ein Dieselfahrzeug
erworben haben können sich Hoffnung auf
Schadensersatz machen denn der
Bundesgerichtshof hat die Hürden für
Entschädigungsklagen deutlich gesenkt
ein Anspruch auf Schadensersatz kann
bestehen wenn in dem Fahrzeug ein
sogenanntes Thermofenster eingebaut ist
Birgit franke hat mehr
Urlaub fühlt sich betrogen 2017 kaufte
einen Mercedes Diesel C220 mit Euro 6
Norm was er nicht ahnt Mercedes aber
auch viele andere Autobauer haben eine
Motorsteuerung eingebaut die bei
kühleren Temperaturen die Abgasreinigung
reduziert oder sogar deaktiviert
sogenannte Thermofenster
sauer das war nicht fair von denen das
sind Weltkonzern wie Mercedes dass sie
sich sowas
leisten die Richterinnen und Richter
Stärken heute die Rechte der Betroffenen
Dieselfahrer der Bundesgerichtshof hat
heute entschieden dass der Käufer eines
mit einer unzulässigen
abschalteinrichtung versehenen Fahrzeugs
von dem Hersteller Schadensersatz
verlangen kann wenn der
herstellerkenntnis hattet fahrlässig
diesbezüglich gehandelt hat entscheidend
ist daneben ob die abschalteinrichtung
in den jeweiligen Automodellen
tatsächlich unzulässig ist die
Hersteller zeigen sich gelassen sie
würden sauber arbeiten
im Fall Volkswagen gibt es keine
unzulässige abschalteinrichtung das KBA
hat hundertfach bestätigt dass in diesem
Fahrzeug keine unzulässige
abschalteinrichtung enthalten ist jetzt
müssen die Vorinstanzen im Einzelfall
noch einmal klären wie es tatsächlich
aussieht
Verbraucherschützer gehen davon aus dass
anhängige Verfahren und schnell
abgewickelt werden auch neue klagen
können sich lohnen bei denen die noch
nichts unternommen haben und die jetzt
erst losziehen wird es länger dauern
aber so wie ich das Urteil einschätze
nicht mehr Jahre es wird eine Instanz
reichen möglicherweise fangen die
Autohersteller auch schon
außergerichtlich anzuzahlen 5 bis 15%
des Kaufpreises können Betroffene
dieselkunden möglicherweise
zurückbekommen
so herrlich der Sommer ist die
zunehmende Hitze belastet auch und wird
Gefahren im vergangenen Jahr starben in
Deutschland etwa 4.500 Menschen Hitze
bedingt vor allem ältere kranke und
Kinder müssen sich schützen bzw müssen
geschützt werden wie das geht darüber
berät der Gesundheitsminister heute mit
einer Expertenrunde Vorbild ist
Frankreich
Frankreich reagierte schon 2003 damals
erfasste eine große Hitzewelle ganz
Europa Paris lernte setzte ein
nationales hitzeschutzprogramm um ein
vierstufen-warnsystem je nach
Temperaturen Luftfeuchtigkeit Frankreich
soll jetzt für Deutschland Vorbild sein
eine solche Initiative ist sehr wichtig
sie kommt zu spät fast 20 Jahre aber
jetzt brauchen wir sie ja für ja sterben
tausende Menschen an Hitze hier in
Deutschland und eine solche Zahl ist
nicht zu tolerieren
ältere Menschen sind besonders gefährdet
Sozialverbände fordern den sofortigen
Einbau von Klimaanlagen in
Pflegeeinrichtungen mindestens aber
einen kühleren Gemeinschaftsraum auch in
Kitas besonders steht der heizen auch
bei hohen Temperaturen Abkühlung ist
wichtig mehr Trinkbrunnen wie in anderen
Städten soll es geben seit heute online
die Website Hitze service.de ein
Ratgeber für Kommunen welche Maßnahmen
bei hohen Temperaturen sinnvoll sind
besonders in akuten Hitzeperioden wir
werden die Menschen auch direkt
ansprechen das kann zum Beispiel so wie
in Frankreich funktionieren dass die
Gemeinden dann zum Beispiel allein
lebende Menschen ansprechen die
Pflegedienste die Pflegenden erreichen
es kann auch sein dass wir sogar direkt
der SMS verschicken also an die
Erkrankung in den besonders gefährdeten
Bereichen noch wird der hitzeplan
beraten heute war erst der Auftakt der
Gespräche während die Temperaturen
draußen steigen viele Maßnahmen könnten
für diesen Sommer zu spät kommen
jetzt zum Sport da steht der deutsche
Fußballnachwuchs mächtig unter
Erfolgsdruck erinnert alles sehr an die
Großen der deutschen U21-Auswahl droht
bei der EM in Georgien und Rumänien als
Titel Verteidiger das Aus in der
Vorrunde nur ein Sieg gegen England und
Schützenhilfe von Israel können am
Mittwoch das vorzeitige Turnierende
abwenden
auch Rudi Völler ist in Georgien dabei
als dfb-direktor der zuletzt schwachen
A-Nationalmannschaft sieht er bei der
eins zu zwei Niederlage der U21 gegen
Tschechien eine Reihe von Schwächen die
ihm bekannt vorkommen die letzten paar
Prozent der Entschlossenheit der
Konsequenzen auch vom gegnerischen
schieben da hat er leider gefehlt und
auch hinten dann muss man auch sagen bei
dem einen anderen Gegenteil auch hinten
die Konsequenz Verhalten ist also ein
bisschen Spiegelbilder zu haben
Mannschaft da haben wir auch schon diese
diese Fehler begangen das Team von
Trainer Antonio de salvo hofft nun fürs
letzte Gruppenspiel gegen England noch
auf den Einsatz des Muskel verletzten
jusufer kommt es zum em aus spielt
Deutschland auch nicht mit bei Olympia
in Paris
der Wechsel von Nationalspieler Ilkay
Gündogan vom triple-gewinner Manchester
City zum FC Barcelona ist perfekt ein
Kindheitstraum sagt der 32-Jährige ja
noch knapp vier Wochen bis zur WM der
Frauen für die die deutsche Mannschaft
noch mehr in Schwung kommen muss
Zufriedenheit dagegen beim Blick auf das
verbesserte Prämiensystem
die stattliche wenn auch immer noch
nicht gleiche Erhöhung der wm-prämien
durch die FIFA fand im deutschen
Trainingslager großen Zuspruch das sind
natürlich sehr sehr zufrieden dass es
auch so eine Entwicklung nimmt aber für
uns steht einfach das sportliche im
Vordergrund und umso schöner wenn es
dann dementsprechend auch mit premier
noch belohnt wird die Stimmung im
deutschen Team ist bestens und
entsprechend selbstbewusst heißt das
Team zur WM der Titel ganz klar also
nicht nur ich persönlich sondern auch
die Mannschaft an sich
fährt zu einem Turnier im Titel zu holen
der Teamgeist gehört für die
Bundestrainerin elementar auch zu jedem
Trainingslager und sie scheint mit ihrer
Mannschaft auf einem sehr guten Weg zu
sein
an den letzten wm-tests gibt es am 7
juli gegen Sambia in Fürth Dankeschön
Christian zum Schluss hier noch eine
sehr besondere Begegnung in Australien
in der Nähe des berühmten bondai Beach
bekommt dieser Kajak-Fahrer Besuch von
einem neugierigen Buckelwal er begleitet
ihn minutenlang bis zum nächsten Strand
zweifellos eindrucksvoll dennoch dürfte
der Mann eine gewisse Erleichterung
verspürt haben als der Wahl abtrete
morgen wird es nicht mehr ganz so warm
aber es gibt erneut Gewitter mehr dazu
gleich von Osten terli im heute journal
um viertel vor zehn spricht Marietta
Slomka mit Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius wir sind danke und tschüss und
bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses Tief hier
auf der Wetterkarte das brachte heute
die kräftigen Gewitter im Norden
Deutschlands zumindest die zogen
allmählich ostwärts und das ganze
verlagert sich raus aus Deutschland im
Süden dauert es länger mit den Gewittern
dahinter kommt kühlere Luft ins Land ja
und in der Nacht gibt es eben noch im
Osten allerletzte Gewitter die ziehen
raus im Süden dauert länger ganz im
Norden einige Schauer die durchziehen
sonst ist es trocken bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 9 Grad im hessischen
Bergland und 16 Grad in Bayern das ist
die Temperaturspanne morgen dann im
Tagesverlauf neue schauen und Gewitter
die von Nordwesten her aufziehen im
Tagesverlauf entwickeln sich auch einige
kräftigere ja und zum Abend hin schwenkt
das nach Süden dann ist es hauptsächlich
Regen aber vorher gibt's noch viel
Sonnenschein z.B in Südwesten bei
höchsten Temperaturen bis 20 Grad z.B an
den Küsten und 27 Grad im Südwesten also
nicht mehr ganz so warm wie die Tage
zuvor der Blick auf die nächsten Tage
einige Schauer am Mittwoch dazwischen
auch viel Sonne bis 27 Grad und ab
Donnerstag nimmt die Gewitter Gefahr
wieder zu und es wird auch heißer damit
ein schöner Abend